hello everyone and welcome to round 11
of the ftx crypto cup the preliminaries
it's a very nice match up magnus carlson
vs hikaru nakamura always an exciting
one
and this game is no different it's much
more exciting than a few of the
previous games that the two of them have
played but you will be the judge of that
as usual
so without further ado let's check it
out magnus has the white pieces and he
opens with
e4 now if you don't remember the
standings these are the standings after
after the 10 rounds have been played so
he called doing extremely well he's the
current leader
uh joined uh with six and a half points
and magnus with five and a half points
um
uh he's uh currently safe he's not
really um
in any danger of not qualifying for the
main event but you
always could uh could do better you know
so e4 by magnus with e5 by hikaru knight
to f3
knights the c6 and the now bishop to c4
hikaru goes bishop to c5 and no it was
not played in this game here magnus goes
for c3
uh the main line of the joker piano we
have knight to f6
d3 and now castles we have knight b
to d2 so just normal developing moves we
have d5
attacking the bishop here e captures
knight captures and now
knight to e4 attacking the dark square
bishop here
with bishop back to e7 and here magnus
castles we have knight to b6
attacking the bishop here bishop to b3
and now the ship to f5 we have a4 uh now
going for a5 so hikaru pushes a5 himself
and interestingly uh topolo hikaru
already had this position against
topalov in a grand prix uh in riga and
that game ended in a draw topalov went
rook to e1 here
but magnus goes to bishop to e3 and it's
not a known move
it has been played before uh but there
is only
one game or maybe two games there is one
uh adiban versus
antonetta stefanova uh where uh knights
uh
uh where uh knights the d5 was played uh
going after this bishop and adiban was
able to win that game it was in
gibraltar masters of 2014
but here we have kinked the h8 by hikaru
and it is now already as of move 12 that
we have a completely new game
he's getting out of this uh long
diagonal so
the bishop will not be able to pose any
problems later on he wants to move the
bishop and play
f5 and start an attack against carlson's
king
so let's see how he deals with this as
this is a completely
new move so here we have rook to e1 by
magnus and the bishop to g6 just
continuing with his plan uh we have
knight to g3
and now uh here magnus is kind of
offering this uh
d3 pawn but not really if you capture it
for example queen captures
uh we can just uh just capture back and
then play bishop cactus and b6 c
captures and now
uh the e5 pawn also falls so captures
captures and captures and we get this
position where
material is equal hikaru has the bishop
pair uh but
his pawn structure is a little bit
messed up and should be white should be
a little bit better here
so instead after this uh uh well pawn
offering hikaru ignores it he plays
knight to d7
and now uh magnus uh not really
in a good position here f5 is coming and
there is not much you can do about it
magnus tries
uh by uh striking in the center with the
d4 and he spent quite a lot of time
uh deciding on this as he's already down
to six minutes some six minutes and 30
seconds
whereas hikaru has a full 12 minutes on
the clock
and he just continues with his plan of
f5
now saying that uh okay if you capture
here i'm just gonna play f4 and i win
uh you you will uh you will have to give
up a piece here
so instead after f5 we have d5 by magnus
uh attacking before hikaru gets the
chance to push
f4 and now knight to b8 he carouses it's
not a problem
uh this knight will rejoin the game
afterwards this knight can come to f6
then this knight to d7
but you still have to worry about f4 so
magnus goes back with bishop to c1
and now uh is the moment where good
things
might happen so here the move hikaru
should play is not push upon
as his pawns are amazing here just
controlling all of these squares uh
magnus not really having any active
active moves
okay the the e5 pawn is hanging so we
might just defend it
and then you then you continue uh you
know building building your game
however hikaru played f4 here a bit
prematurely maybe and
he uh just allowed magnus some very
natural developing moves so now he gets
his knight to the e4
and this is now an excellently placed
knight we have knight to a6 by hikaru
uh preparing to bring this knight back
into the game uh and now
bishop the c2 uh we have rook to e8
and now b3 by magnus and now bishop to
f6 but now already
uh if you compare this position to the
position where the pawns were still on
e5 and
f5 and all of these squares were
controlled the knights still
not doing all that great on g3 this
position is much much better for magnus
and he plays bishop to a3 to prove it
now controlling this beautiful diagonal
here
gaining more control of the d6 square
and now uh it's not really easy to
counter this if you just go back bishop
to e7 then we can just play d6 and this
is
now better for white for example if we
capture on d6
captures uh with the knight attacks the
rook here so bishop captures we're first
going to capture the bishop on g6 and
now
for example captures queen captures and
this is just a beautiful position for
white this rook is coming to d1 the g6
spawn is hanging
uh the e5 pawn is hanging everything is
attacking it so it's just a much much
better position for white
so instead hikaru goes knight to b6 but
uh magnus uh continues pushing all the
same he just plays d6 here
so what do you play here uh well what
you want to do is basically just
uh eliminate this past pawn uh it's not
a passport yet it first has to
deal with this tension but if you
eliminate it uh then we play knight
captures attack the rook and after the
rook moves
now we play bishop captures on g6 h
captures and knight to f7 check
and we win the black queen there are
some other lines
of course black can choose but all of
them are are pretty bad
so instead after d6 he can't really
allow such things he car plays c6 but
this now also means that magnus has now
a beautiful defended pass pawn on d6 so
here we have queen to e2
uh the pawn is sufficiently defended so
you can now
develop the queen you want to bring the
other rook into the game as well
knight to d7 by hikaru and now rook a to
d1
so this is a very very very difficult to
play for black we have bishop to h5
now pinning the knight if the queen
moves maybe you can open up
the white king's position a little bit
and here magnus just plays b4
and now the situation on the clock if
you remember magnus was uh very much
down on the clock now now the situation
on the clock is both players have some 2
minutes and 30 seconds on the clock
so here uh hikaru uh grabs on b4 once
we have cactus on b4 and now queen to b6
uh developing the queen now also he
might be able to activate those rooks
but now magnus just pushes b5
and here you maybe you don't want to
capture on b5 maybe
you want to play some like knight eight
to c5 and then do some trades on c5 and
if white wants white can capture here
uh but hikaru says uh that no i'm gonna
capture
on b5 by by just capturing first
uh we have eight captures and now knight
eight to b8 and now
uh those knights are not uh don't really
have
anything to do here is it just a really
really tough position
uh the the bishop here is under attack
so here we're just going to play bishop
to b4 this is what magnus played
and now all of these squares are nicely
covered so the knight really cannot
go anywhere at some point you're going
to have to move this knight
to bring this knight here and then well
all in all it's going to be very
very difficult to develop these knights
so here uh we have knights the
fade by hikaru he has to try it somehow
now comes
knight the c3 going after this d5 square
to attack the queen and the bishop in
just the knight on d5 is going to be an
extremely
strong piece so queen back to d8 and now
knight to d5 uh we have rook to a2
hikaru spots this very active move now
but it's uh maybe not active enough
because magnus just plays
queen to c4 and says what is this rook
even doing here
i will show it there is one move here
that is really really strong so
if you guys want maybe you can even
maybe even pause the video and try and
find it because it's it's a really nice
position so it'd be a shame
and not to explore it so uh play a move
with white
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding the uh
strongest attacking move uh as you
always do
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's knight to e7
it's just a beautiful bone in black's
throat and there's nothing black can do
about this you cannot
capture this knight it really would
serve no purpose because the bishop is
also
helping out with the defense also you
don't want to open up the rook here
and another thing it does it keeps an
eye on the g6 square so
this queen for for example can come to
d3 and then you're going to have
this queen going for this uh h7
square and there there's really not all
that much you can do here it's just a
beautiful position and black is
basically without a move here
so knights the e7 would have been very
impressive but they are both
very low on the clock so magnus goes
queen to c4 it's also a very nice move
uh and now hikaru doesn't want to go
back and give magnus a
more free tempe he just eliminates it to
get rid of this knight and open up the
white king
so here queen captures bishop captures
an f3
g captures and now queen to d7 trying to
maybe uh get this queen into the game
maybe you can get queen h3 and then
maybe knight can come to g6 the h4 maybe
you can deliver checkmate with queen to
g2
uh who knows what might happen uh magnus
goes knight
to c7 now attacks the rook here and rook
to d8
we have queen to c4 magnus improving the
position of his queen
and now queen to h3 uh the move doesn't
really do anything but still
uh with under a minute on the clock it's
uh maybe not
the most pleasant move to face uh so
here rook to d3
now defending the f3 pawn and now knight
b to d7
the problem is you wanna uh start by
going something like this and then
uh deliver checkmate here the problem is
if you uh
leave control of the e6 square uh magnus
can just play queen to e6 and i'll offer
a queen trade and that's it now you
really don't have any
uh any good moves you are down the
exchange and that's not
the the way to go so here knight beat
the d7 by hikaru
and now queen test queen to f7 like
hikaru magnus now plays a scary move
with his queen
and now uh hikaru has to watch out for
for a lot of things so here we have
bishop the
h4 now even with some ideas of maybe
sacrificing the bishop here king
captures queen captures and h2 maybe
good things can happen here
so magnus just defends against this he
plays rook to e2 and now
knight to f6 and here uh there's a
well there's a really really scary move
here and i know you guys know which
movie it is without even pausing the
video
uh so i'm i'm just going to show it to
you
uh magnus did not play it magnus played
is something else but uh
we're gonna show it it's d7 d7 is a is a
very nice move here because it just uh
attacks the knight twice i mean and
there is not much you can do here now
you can start uh by capturing on d7 and
even though yes you lose a pawn yeah it
doesn't matter
knight to e6 attacks the rook and also
threatens checkmate
so you'd have to defend rook to g8 and
now rook to c3 but this is
of course impossible to find with such
little time on the clock and now
uh there's simply no defense black will
black's only defense is to play queen f5
to go for this queen g6 check to try and
trade queens
white will play rook the c8 now of
course if you capture on c8 then just uh
queen captures and g7 checkmate
so you have to go for this queen trade
and now we're going to play captures
captures
rook captures king captures and now it
doesn't really matter bishop to d6 or
anything
and uh white is just what is just
winning here because well
you are up material so this is one way
to do it the magnus played bishop to c3
but bishop to c3 offers hikaru
a lot more a lot more squares because
now he gets his queen into the game with
tempo now the rook on d3 is under attack
uh
magnus brings it back to d1 and now
queen to h3
again hikaru just asks what what are we
playing here i'm planning to capture
here on f3
magnus repeats and hikaru repeats again
and he says
uh i'm very happy with the draw i'm very
lucky to have survived this long
uh what do you want to do and here
magnus not interested in draw he plays
rook e to d2
now uh giving hikaru even more chances
uh and now hikaru plays e4 and e4 is not
the move you want to play uh e4 is uh
well there's something that loses the
game for hikaru but again with so little
time on the clock it's very easy to miss
uh rook to d5 uh just attack the queen
uh the knight of course cannot capture
because the queen captures queen
and after the queen moves uh we happily
trade for example captures uh and now
knight can capture on
on d7 we're gonna capture on f6 knight
captures now play knight the e6
attack the rook if the rook moves uh we
don't really
uh we don't really care uh so probably
black will just capture here we're gonna
capture blackstroke
and now again we're gonna enjoy this
position uh we are up material this
night is
the night is under attack once the night
moves we can start pushing our past pawn
it is a completely winning position
however a
little time on the clock let's not
forget that uh bishop captures on f6
is what was played by magnus uh here
hikaru grabbed back the ship captures
and now rook to d5 attacking the black
queen but now
queen to c8 so it is a little bit
different we have b6
uh now cementing that knight on c7 and
now comes
e3 by hikaru again uh finding the only
moves uh
the position is most of the times lost
for hikaru here but he finds the only
moves
uh that pose problems for magnus so here
magnus goes d7
uh try saying that okay you capture my
rook i'm going to capture your queen
here
so here we have knight captures on d7
and
now comes rook to d1 and this rook to d1
is another mistake by magnus
uh you have to capture first and then
play anything like rook to d3 and then
if the pawn moves you can play king to
f2
and then you don't really care about
black's past pawn anymore however after
knight captures on d7 magnus played
rooked at d1
and now e2 is a bit of a problem because
you can't go up
uh e1 will just be queen so here rook
the e1 was played but now
uh magnus no longer has doubled rooks in
the d file we have knight to e5 now
hikaru with the threat of just knight
captures on f3
so magnus gives back the exchange we
have rook captures
bishop captures and now king the g2 and
here he carl played rook to f8 and
uh believe it or not it was in this
position on move 51 that the players
agreed to a draw
uh really insane stuff uh magnus uh
had so many so many possibilities but
hikaru
in these uh insane positions hikaru is
just uh
like we already mentioned that there's
the that one video that i made
hikaru truly seems to be immortal
uh so really really uh outstanding and
here you draw because
once the queen moves uh there's really
not all that much you can do black can
just capture here and after let's say
uh let's say queen captures uh on c7
uh you can ignore this play queen t8 you
defend your past pawn and
there is really nothing much white can
white can hope for here
uh if you go for this pawn we can go for
queen to g6
check and now it's a really really an
ugly position here king h1 we're gonna
play h6 uh
to avoid any uh future uh
future mistakes uh like like a back rank
mate and
this is just uh always gonna be a
problem of course if you capture this
then queen to b1 check can be played and
then for example if king to g to now we
can play rook f6 go after
rook to g6 and created an attack and we
don't care about any back rank issues
because we played h6 so
this is not a position where you want to
look for your chances after rook to f8
they agreed to a draw
and this is just uh incredible so there
were many
great moments in this game many mistakes
uh and
well many winning chances but uh we all
know
what was uh carlson's biggest mistake in
not winning this game
uh it was of course in this position uh
when he could have played before he
played c3
he angered the chess gods and of course
it doesn't matter if he was plus 10 plus
100 plus 1 000 in the end
uh there was just no winning uh
disposition you always have to play the
evan's gambit that that's just the way
chess works
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it a nice start to day three
we'll see
who will qualify in the end for the main
event uh i would like to thank mr hoodie
guy
uh boris um devon shah and aman patel
barry mcmurdock and
mesh mahajan for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this very nice event
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day